a special event was held in the west  valley today to show support for  everyone in law enforcement  it's a great way for us to walk around  and meet our brothers and sisters in  blue  just thank them for being there because  you know we all do this because we love  our community we all do this because we  like working together and it's just a  great way for the community to come  together and  celebrate law enforcement on such a  beautiful day  the city of las vegas partnered with the  team at behind the blue for law  enforcement appreciation day it was held  at police memorial park every local  department was there not just to connect  with families but also with each other